proud to call this man a friend got to
meet him many many moons ago he's made
several appearances here on the Rich
Eisen show in our six year history was
even on our podcast back in the NFL
media group days and the actor and
author and stage performer is now a
podcaster he's got a new podcast that is
available where all podcasts can be
gotten called literally with Rob Lowe
Rob Lowe here on the Rich Eisen show how
are you rob I'm literally here on tell
you are in fact doing that did I did I
say the title correctly because there is
an exclamation point in the title and
I'm I don't know if it's if it's silent
or it is like the comma and murder
pro-pro exclamation points okay almost
every sentence I say has an exclamation
point at the end of it yes right there
literally with Rob Lowe why uh why the
pod Rob where did this come from you
know what I have always liked long-form
interviews you and I get to do them I
enjoy being on them and I have such a
long history with interesting people
that I thought there'd be some value in
me talking to people that that I'm never
I'm gonna be able to know things about
them because of our shared history that
others are never gonna know like Magic
Johnson is my next guest last week right
now the podcast that's out is with Chris
Pratt who I've known since he was you
know chubby Andy Dwyer and Parks and Rec
and then became ripped shredded movie
syrup man so my perspective on my
relationship with him is very very
different than others with magic you
know I can be like do you remember when
Riley banished me from traveling with
the team
you're not gonna get those kind of talks
with with web reasonless I'm doing the
talking okay so now the Riley would be
packed
I assume flick Pat Riley okay so unpack
this story for me Rob I know I don't
want to give away too much that's on
literally with Rob Lowe but he bet he
banned you from the traveling with the
team yeah and what was so great about
this is because I know my side of the
story
uh-huh but I don't know magic side of
the story he was aware of it or maybe he
caused it maybe you know for all I knew
he was I get that guy out of here I just
don't know so I asked him and he started
laughing and he said oh absolutely I
remember it well you know Riley didn't
want any distractions your honor those
days you know I was kind of teen idol
time so wherever I went was like a posse
of of young fans yeah but here's the
part I didn't know that magic tour
videos yes yeah no they they wouldn't
even let our married players wives come
to the hotel so they made you go stay at
that hotel like wait a minute
me staying with the wives doesn't sound
good oh so how did you get to try how
did you come about to travel with the
Lakers to begin with though wrong well
at that point of my life I was single I
was in my early 20s and you know huge
sports fan right I would you know do
movies and then in my time off you know
I had the time and I loved the game so
much so you know I'd season seats and
all of that but I only really want on
the road for the playoffs and but that
was the best that's when he wanted to go
on the road well I mean Riley wants to
tighten the rotation in the playoffs Rob
and I'm sure you've seen Pat since many
times I imagine he's just you know
there's nobody like him either isn't I
pointed out to magic balls on the
podcast that the Lakers are the are
known for having a coach who never sat
down yeah Pat never took a seat ever in
any game he ever coached
not once so going to a coach who never
stood up its in phil jackson right yeah
it's because when phil would have to
unfold himself to stand up you know I
mean Phillip Phil's kind of you know
he's got a lot of moving parts when he
just walks around and stands up you know
but that's right Riley never sat never
get that great kind of Riley squat that
I think David Caruso's soils Miami and
David Caruso comes into a crime scene
he's doing the Pat Riley Rob Rob for our
Super Bowl this year which was in Miami
I for our Super Bowl open I played the
David Caruso character with a red wig in
all I will send you I will send you the
photographs and even one of the show
opens that I did where I did at one
point we actually even got Rex Linn to
play to reprise his character oh yes and
part of the open was you know with the
whole you know music and everything was
me getting down squatting down like
David Caruso and standing over a first
down marker to see if it was a first
down with a football and also using
forceps to pick up a yellow flag and and
and bag it like it was a like it was
something from a crime scene
oh just all of them I don't you know I
don't remember anything specifically but
they all were done when delivering them
putting the glasses on that was the
Caruso move it wasn't taking the glasses
off and delivering the line it was the
glasses on I think hopefully they said
captain do you think it's a first down
and you do your squad to guys and it's
not the only thing that's going down
music but me being a fifty year old man
I did need on occasion to help getting
up to be very honest with you you know
because he really went down I mean the
squad he did get the squad Riley I'm
just telling you
Rob Lowe here on the rich odds that you
anything else did you chat it up with
the magic that you want to I know I have
a really great lineup coming in I you
know one of Paltrow I think is gonna be
the next guest okay and you know my wife
and I have known Glen us since she was
an 18 year old staying in our guest
bedroom meeting with agents so now were
you like friendly with blythe danner
with her whether a mom
with her mom and her dad Bruce maestro
of course and here's a little factoid
yes that Mike Meyers also a guest coming
up who does not do a lot of podcast so
it was great to have the comic genius
Mike Meyers talks about how he based his
character of The Cat in the Hat on
Gwen's dad Bruce Paltrow which is the
most random oh gosh choice yes if you
ever watch The Cat in the Hat he's
literally hence my title is literally
yes Bruce Paltrow okay so you got that
connection right there and and again
just reading your I mentioned you as an
author but to introduce you stories I
only tell my friends an autobiography is
truly a must read the stories that you
have and the people that you have come
across in your career Rob and also
growing up is a is a Charlie Sheen
appearance in the offing for you that
would be an entire season literally me I
mean you you would have to go to Abbas
Apple Spotify and just you'd have to
reserve you know too many more future
seasons and then what about Tom Cruise
can we get Tom oh no they're all they're
all in the mix for sure okay it's been
it's been a very eclectic group and and
it's been
way more fun than I thought it would be
a nice thought it would be fun to begin
with or I wouldn't have done it the
first place it has been I mean I'm
envious of what you get to do you're a
curious dude you're smart you're funny
you get to you get to talk to people and
have interesting conversations it's been
great I may give it up I may never act
again a lot of people happy about that I
I may just be doing my podcast
what would crews call your pod would he
call it I did low I mean Rob what we do
what do you say the story you're
alluding to Tom famously shortened the
titles of all of his movies and I
thought it was the coolest thing ever as
a young actor like he did a movie called
all the right moves limo player right
and he was like yeah man I had to do a
lot of training what does it move and I
was really cool but then when he did
short short title movies it was a little
more awkward like we needed cocktail
[Applause]
that would be a conundrum
that'd be somewhat of a conundrum about
that you would do you would do low or
you do you did man I would be remiss if
I did not ask you about st. Elmo's fire
sir since Joel Schumacher the director
of this film passed away just what was
that earlier this week there's earlier
this week what a life he had what an
amazing he started out as literally a
junkie on the streets of New York and
then was a design the windows Macy's
department store and then into
production design and writing and
directing and then making some of the
most iconic movies you know of his error
and he was really responsible for a big
uptick in my career because that part of
Billy and seeing almost fire was
something that people really gravitated
to and no one wanted me to play that
part except Joel he everybody thought I
should play the Judd Nelson part
sort of yuppie square and I wanted to
play Billy because it's about a report
and they didn't believe I could be a bad
boy
so I remember showing up with a six-pack
at the meeting with Joel and just
drinking it like just getting hammered
and next thing you know I got you just
six and then you just I brought a sixer
in and it was it was quite funny those
were the days man those when you when
you could have a good excuse for your
alcoholism
it was great now is this the time when
you were barred from traveling with the
Lakers was this the Rob Lowe did where
you are we is this hear it now that
you're calling my attention back to it
the fact that I was showing up to work
meetings with it with a six-pack
probably why Pat Riley didn't want me
around the team oh my gosh yeah this is
this was 1985 Yeah right man what a view
during the quarantine turned on anything
that you from your from your career and
you're like I forgot or about this or
man this really brings back memories
anything that you turned on on the TV
and you saw something you know they've
been they've been running a lot of some
of the old stuff a lot of Parks and Rec
right it's been out on which is great
and you know people are still watching
the West Wing the more the political
situation gets crazier the more right
people go back to the west wing for
comfort and the west wing now plays like
a sci-fi movie it's it seems so unreal
and it's fun to go back and look at
those those things and kind of kind of
won't they more than stand up and I love
that I'm able to be a part of this too
well I'm looking forward to your future
episodes of your pod your stories are
amazing
and it this this format is perfect for
them so you know I I can't wait to hear
Mike Meyers come on you could tell
stories about powers and and world right
when you did those all right it should
be Wayne's it wouldn't be hooted
you did Wayans Wayans powers and you
know without you know - by the way I was
thinking of Chris Farley and David Spade
and this week is the 25th anniversary of
boy no kidding are you serious
25 years since that boy came out
wow you're free well are ya I guess
because you can't eat Tommy Tommy Tommy
it's - well people would also think it
might be the the movie with the who you
know what I mean I think I was I was
Pete Townsend crashing you know speaking
of which I had placed in my hand during
this conversation by our social media
grand maester TJ Jefferson the lines
that I did have as David Caruso in okay
so the concept of the show opened was
that the Lombardi Trophy had been stolen
okay because again this is for the Super
Bowl this is the greatest idea ever
okay so here's my here's a line when
when trip is is looking at me Rex Linn
is looking at me I say I find that
trophy trip I'm gonna find it because
when I play I play to win
okay another one no Lombardi Trophy no
ball game that's when we find out two
suspects trip I'm about to bench these
guys because this is one whale of a
party foul the great Colin Hanks aside a
cameo as the boat captain that was
eventually arrested for this heinous
crime
[Laughter]
Rob Lowe to connect these dots Hanks
family insists on playing boat captain
so I looked at Colin who by the way
cracked me up I was very difficult for
me to keep a straight face don't sail
too far from shore captain you're not
off the hook yes okay and then when he's
finally taken away in handcuffs this was
the last line of cuz he was it was like
an episodic each day we were on the air
for five days we advanced the plot with
a different open each day so this was
the way it ended Rob that's the as Colin
Hanks is being led off by by rekhs line
that's the end of regulation skipper
game over
as I put the glasses on and I was in so
the next time I come on your show I'm
going to explain then this is a true
story that David Caruso told all the
writers and producers on that show that
he his character was actually a ghost
for the next experience of the Rob Lowe
appearance on the show if you like these
kind of stories this is why I have a
podcast now you must literally download
it the ghosts thought he was playing a
ghost so I'm going to say I thought it
was an apocryphal story like you know or
an urban legend yeah and I've since met
multiple people multiple people writers
producers who are like oh yeah oh no
yeah when you come on the show as a
writer you have to go to David's trailer
and get the talk and he tells you that
he's playing the gut that Horatio
kanizsa is a spirit crimes and just on a
practical level apparently what that
meant was he doesn't like to be filmed
entering and exiting oh because he would
sashay all over the place you notice he
never really you never go who's that oh
the ratio to you never need to walk
through doors no no you're right walls
doesn't matter Wow criminals don't stand
a chance against the spirit that is
Horatio King and that's why I like
Halloween Rob thanks for the call you
take care yourself we'll chat right back
down literally with Rob Lowe that's the
latest podcast oh my gosh that guy hey
you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here